THE STATE OF EBAY:
Aside from Amazon, eBay is likely the most
well known online retailer in the entire world.
They been around for nearly 30 years and they rank
as the 23rd most visited website in the US pulling
in more than 600 million visits every single
month. For perspective, that’s nearly double
the visits that Netflix gets. But legacy and
popularity are pretty much the only things that
eBay still has going for them. Behind the scenes,
eBay has been facing a decline for basically this
entire century. In fact, the only time that eBay
stock has seen a significant surge over the
past 25 years was when they decided to spin
off PayPal into its own business in 2015. Before
that, eBay stock was mostly flat, and after that,
eBay stock has been mostly flat as well aside
from the pandemic boost which has completely
dissipated. For contrast, here’s how Amazon’s
stock graph looks over the same time period. And
when we take a look at the company’s fundamentals,
it’s not surprising why. eBay’s revenue today is
about the same as it was back in 2010. And things
only look worse in terms of net income. As recent
as last year, eBay had a negative 12 month
period where they lost $1.2 billion. Since then,
they have recovered back into the green, but
again, the numbers really aren’t all that
much better than they were back in 2010. The one
thing that eBay has going for them is that their
net margins of 27% are leagues ahead of Amazon who
sits at just 3.62%. However, it doesn’t seem like
investors really care much about this as their
far more optimistic about Amazon’s future. That’s
why Amazon still has a PE ratio of 80 while eBay
only has a PE ratio of 8. Even IBM has a PE ratio
of 21 meaning that investors are almost 3 times
more optimistic about IBM than eBay. And when
you consider that many analysts consider eBay
to be all but dead, their lackluster valuation
isn’t all that surprising, but it does leave the
question of what in the world happened to eBay?
UNHAPPY SELLERS:
When you scour the web
for concerns regarding eBay, one of the biggest
concerns seems to be that sales are falling off
a cliff. And this sentiment has especially
picked up over the past 6 months. There’s a
bunch of prevalent theories floating around.
For example, student loan payments restarted
recently meaning that a lot of people now have
less disposable income. Inflation and high
interest rates have also been been eating into
people’s savings. Some sellers even speculate
that the sales drought may have been caused by an
eBay algorithm change in April. On the surface,
it seems that a lot of these explanations make
sense but the evidence doesn’t exactly back up
these theories. For example, Amazon and Walmart
are still posting record revenue numbers. And
eBay themselves are posting relatively
flat revenue. Not to mention, concerns
about falling sales seems to be a constant theme
throughout history. In basically any given year,
you can go onto reddit and find a bunch of sellers
claiming that sales are worse than ever. With that
being said though, that doesn’t necessarily mean
that they’re wrong. The reality is that selling on
eBay is harder than ever but not because of macro
economic reasons but competition. Back in 2009,
eBay only had a total of 2.1 million annual active
sellers. Today, eBay has a total of 18.3 million
annual active sellers or 9 times more. It’s
a similar case with Amazon but there’s one
crucial difference. Amazon’s revenue has grown
22X since 2009. eBay’s revenue on the other had
has only increased 15%. And a lot of that can
be explained by consistently increasing fees.
If we take a look at the gross merchandize volume
going through eBay, we can see that the figure is
lower today than it was back in 2013. And that’s
not even accounting for inflation. Since 2009,
prices have gone up by 43% meaning that flat
revenue could actually be indicative of up
to 30% lower unit sales. And given that eBay’s
overall transactional revenue itself is down,
eBay’s overall unit sales could actually be down
by as much as 40%. When you combine 40% lower unit
sales with 9 times the number of sellers, it’s no
wonder why sellers are always complaining about
sales going down. The reality is that it could
be as much 10 to 15 times harder to get a sale
today than it was back in 2009, and all of that
is just on the seller side of things. The buyer
side of things don’t look any better as eBay has
been shedding users like the plague. In fact,
they didn’t even enjoy bounce during the pandemic.
Their peak user count was back in 2018 when they
had 175 million annual users. Today, that number
stands at 129 million users or nearly 50 million
less. And this is of course anecdotal but if you
Google “I will never buy from eBay again”, you get
dozens upon dozens of links. That’s not how it is
with Amazon or Walmart or even Craigslist. Sure,
they have few threads like that here and there but
with eBay, it’s basically ubiquitous. And when you
combine this anecdotal evidence with the fact that
eBay is down nearly 50 million buyers, its clear
that these threads aren’t just from disgruntled
customers. Rather, it seems to be a serious
problem with eBay as a whole which brings us into
the question of why are customers so mad at eBay?
UNHAPPY BUYERS:
Reading through the
dozens of negative threads about eBay, it seems
that by far the biggest complaint from buyers
is prevalence of scams on eBay. You know, not
receiving the product, counterfeit products,
damaged products, empty boxes, fake tracking
numbers, and so on. Most of these scams are
covered by eBay’s money back guarantee policy,
but going through that process is usually not
all that fun even if you do end up getting your
money back. So, naturally, buyers are preferring
to shop at other retailers where scams are much
less prevalent like Amazon which brings me into
the primary difference between Amazon and eBay:
FBA. If you’re not familiar with FBA, it stands
for Fulfilled By Amazon and it’s basically the
bread and butter of the entire site. You see,
Amazon isn’t just a marketplace like eBay or
Craiglists, it’s much more of a traditional
retailer as they take on the entire responsibility
of customer service. Everything from distributing
inventory across the country, routing orders,
labeling, and 2 day shipping to handling returns,
covering damages, and customer service. That’s
what Amazon FBA offers. The only thing that
sellers have to do on Amazon is create a listing
and send inventory to Amazon and Amazon will take
care of the rest. Now technically, sellers can
still elect to do all of this themselves but
94% of sellers just go through Amazon FBA. And
the 6% of sellers that don’t use Amazon FBA are
usually big brands who can handle it themselves.
Ironically, even a lot of big brands like Samsung
prefer to just go through Amazon FBA themselves.
What this all means is that you virtually never
interact with the seller on Amazon, you basically
only interact with Amazon. Amazon even goes as far
as taking responsibility for shipping and
order related mishaps. For example, if a
customer leaves a poor review because of a lost or
damaged package, not only will Amazon remove the
negative review but they will reimburse both the
buyer and seller because it was Amazon’s fault,
not the buyer or sellers. And that’s why the
service is so consistent and reliable especially
in comparison to eBay where it truly is just a
marketplace of buyers and sellers. The quality
of service you receive is largely dependent
on how much the given seller cares and it’s
largely up to you to look out for yourself. eBay
did launch their own fulfillment service in mid
2019 but it never quite caught on like Amazon FBA
did because eBay sellers often vastly different
goals. A bunch of eBay listings are just people
selling one off items that they no longer need
for which a fulfillment service doesn’t really
make sense. A fulfillment service makes much more
sense if you’re trying to build a full on business
around a given product that you plan on selling in
large quantities. So, with that being said, I
don’t think eBay’s consistency and reliability
will be improving anytime soon which brings one
the root question which is: why even use eBay?
A DYING PLATFORM:
Taking a step back, the biggest problem with
eBay is that they offer no real value for what
they charge. They’re over hear charging sellers
15% on a bunch of categories just like Amazon does
but they don’t offer any of the perks that Amazon
does. They don’t have the same reliability, the
reputation, or the convenience. They’re more like
a flea market that truly just connects buyers
and sellers which in itself isn’t a bad thing.
There’s definitely a place for this sort of market
online, but if this truly is just a flea market
that doesn’t come with any of the protctions that
Amazon on the buyer side or on the seller side,
why even bother with eBay? eBay is essentially
charging Amazon or Walmart level fees while
offering Craigslist or Facebook marketplace
level of service. If this was a new business,
eBay wouldn’t even stand a chance, but since
they’re established and have brand recognition,
a lot of people still shop on eBay from time to
time until they get burned after which they never
return. The people who want more reliability and
convenience just switch to buying and selling on
Amazon while the people who don’t care to have a
deadweight middle party like eBay just switch to
Craigslist. The only unique reason to come to eBay
at this point is their auctions which themselves
have a bunch of shortfalls like people placing
bids that they have no intention of following
through with. And I think all of these relative
shortfalls can be explained by the fundamentally
different business models of Amazon, eBay, and
Craigslist. Jeff Bezos has always believed that
other people’s margin is his opportunity. This
is how he built up Amazon and its still how it
runs today. That’s why Amazon is able to offer
so much value for the prices they charge. They
simply just don’t make money. Remember how we
talked about Amazon’s margins being 3.62%? Well,
that’s with AWS propping up their retail numbers.
Without AWS, Amazon’s operating margin is closer
to 1.8% and it’s often negative actually. The
reality is that Amazon doesn’t care all that much
about making money from theri retail operation.
Their retail business is more about market
control, brand awareness, and influence. They’re
real money maker is AWS. Meanwhile, Craigslist
doesn’t really care at all to maximize profits.
They’re almost run like a non-profit with very
modest profits and they have no plans of changing.
So, eBay is basically competing against two zero
margin businesses and they’re getting squeezed
from both sides. And the more time that pases,
the more apparent eBay’s 27% margin becomes in
comparison to the competition. The worst part
is that there is no obvious solution. They don’t
have an AWS that they can rely on for profits.
Actually technically, they did use to have all of
PayPal but that’s no longer the case. And I think
it’s safe to assume that eBay also does not want
to become a quasi non profit like Craigslist. So,
they’re kind of stuck between a rock and hard
place. The only way they can really move forward
is by sacrificing profits and becoming more
competitive but that’s not something they really
want to do. So instead, they’ve basically just
decided to enjoy the traffic and profits while
they last which should still be for quite some
time. When things become unsustainable, well,
they’ll deal with it then. And that right there
is the sad state of eBay. They’ve been reduced
from being one of the most dominant online
retailers to resorting to milking sellers as
much as possible while they still can. Unlike
eBay, Craigslist has a much happier ending
as they truly know who they are and what they
stand for. Check out this video to learn more.